okay real quick before I start I just
wanted to point out that there's a
theory out on reddit that actually just
came out a few days ago that's pretty
similar to what I'm going to be talking
about in this video not like super
similar but pretty similar I just wanted
to point out that I did not i repeat did
not steal anything from this or any
other source for my video here I say
this because I know there's someone out
there that's already down in those
comments typing out that and then be
stole this idea as I speak yeah I see
you you know who you are
Oh anyway now that that's out of the way
let's talk about that breath of the wild
2 trailer why don't we now there are
many strange things that either happen
or are shown in this trailer as I'm sure
everyone is pretty familiar with by now
besides the most notable events like you
know the green hand or ganondorf's neck
thing or The Wrap getting wasted there
are some details in the background that
we've all picked apart several times
over the past year you've got yours own
eye architecture the strange platform
zoo that ganondorf's body is placed on
but most importantly for this video the
luminous stones that are increasingly
present the more Link and Zelda venture
towards ganador s-- location and by
increasingly present I mean that quite
literally
we're shown these glowing rocks directly
in three different scenes the first time
there's three then when they've stopped
by the waterside there's like nine then
when they're crossing the bridge there
are like at least twelve some of which
are giant compared to the others and
possibly more in the background now as
cool as these luminous stones look in
the dark you've got to ask yourself why
Nintendo decided to tease these stones
in this place and in this fashion and
why it seems like our fateful duo is
heading towards some sort of huge
collection of the mineral since its
numbers are increasing as we move on but
then they stumble upon Ganondorf and the
hand holding him down now here's where
things get even more interesting the
color of the luminous material is quite
strange indeed since the ghostly hand
that has its nails dug into ganondorf's
chest is colored very very similarly and
you know what else is colored quite
similarly the ghosts or spirits of the
deceased champions and the king from the
first game the luminous stones the
glowing hand and the souls of the
deceased could it be that these all have
something in particular in common with
the
each other that may help explain the
strange placement of the luminous
materials and even the hand itself as
shown in the trailer well I happened to
believe so since I made this video and
all and yeah I'm sure this may have
already been covered by somebody at this
point but to be honest there's so much
breath of the wild to speculation out
there that I've honestly resorted to
just not listening to it anymore
plus I've never actually covered the
glowing hand on this channel so I
figured it's about time you guys heard
my thoughts on the matter also this has
been one of the longest intros I've ever
scripted so now let's dive into the
Luminous Mysteries of breath of the wild
- it occurred to me a while back while
thinking about this that the inclusion
of luminous material may be related to
the exclusion of a classic zelda enemy
ghosts or spirits or pose now let me
explain we know that luminous stones
glow and we know that they glow not
because of natural causes but because of
supernatural means the in-game
description describes luminous stones as
glowing because they're infused with the
quote souls of the Dead this is further
supported since we see that the King and
four champions all share this very
similar luminescent glowing color in
their death and when you're talking
about game design choices color is
extremely important to relay all sorts
of stuff towards the players like
emotions or ideas or even affiliations
and Nintendo games are prime examples of
this concept the similarity of color
here is no mistake at all in fact it's
done for many different things
throughout the game for instance all of
the champions and even Link and Zelda
have deep blue clothing or a blue sash
somewhere on themselves to signify their
allegiance as a champion of Hyrule and
their descendants are all connected the
same way calamity Galan's calamity
Ganon's malice all carries the same
color tones of this dark purple slash
glowing pinkish red the ancient energy
that the sheikah harness for all of
their inventions is all alight neon blue
color and here we are with luminous
stones and literal dead people sharing
the same glowing greenish blue color so
how do you pose tie into all of this
well let's talk first about what a Poe
is since if breath of the wild was your
first Zelda game humane
pose are the spirits of the deceased
that are normally encountered as evil
ghosts that try to you know kill link
their appearances range from game to
game like an ocarina of time where
they're all really short flying people
with arms and a lantern or maybe they're
displaying heads with arms in a lantern
and wind waker where they're full-bodied
humanoids that where jump suits and
masks and hold lanterns or in Twilight
Princess where they're terrified with
lanterns of course and while every Poe I
just showed you is an enemy to link some
pose are actually nice guys like the
composer brothers from ocarina of time
that yes you do have to fight at first
but it's revealed afterwards that they
were just testing you and they then aid
link on his quest and by the way I have
a pretty cool theory about them that'll
link to in the description below and on
the screen if you'd like to check that
out anyway there's also a friendly Poe
that guides you through the desert
sandstorm when trying to reach the
spirit temple because of this variation
I tend to believe that Poe's are not
necessarily all evil inherently but are
simply ghosts of dead people's this is
also supported by the fact that the
ghost hunter is called the ghost hunter
and not the Poe hunter yet he collects
Poe's meaning saying Poe's and ghosts is
most likely synonymous now using this
logic you might be able to figure out
where I'm going with this when I said
earlier that Poe's the classic Zelda
enemy were missing from death of the
wild I kind of sort of lied a little bit
because they are in the game just not as
enemies this is a Poe
this is a Poe these are also posed
they're ghosts of the Dead that you even
have an ethereal fire burning around
them just like the fire burning in pole
and urns actually fire signifies dead
people or spirits a lot in the zelda
franchise like after you defeat a Poe in
ocarina of time or the spirits flying
around the ghost ship in Wind Waker or
the spirits of souls trapped in Twilight
in Twilight Princess pose are even known
to possess or infuse in to people or
things like when a Poe will literally
possess Lincoln Wind Waker or when
they're infused into masks in Majora's
Mask and by the way that kind of sheds a
different light on the happy mask
salesman doesn't it I mean if he's
collecting and selling masks and the
masks are infused with Poe's that makes
him pretty similar to a certain other
character we know but anyway that's
besides the point not only do these
Poe's in breath of the wild burn with a
spiritual flame but the champion pose
also possess the divine be
which is pretty typical po like behavior
if you ask me but if there are pose in
the game why do none of them show up in
the fields of Hyrule as hostile towards
link like they did in previous games
well what if I told you that everyone's
favorite accordion playing traveling
singer/songwriter bird known as cast may
hold the answer
Cass is known for one thing his songs
and his theme that's way too catchy but
one of the songs he sings could pertain
to the history surrounding luminous
stones one of his verses goes a little
something like this
but Ganon lurked beneath the surface
strengthening its jaws so the ancient
people of Hyrule set out to help the
cause their efforts bore fruit in an
automated force to help avert calamity
Ganon by sealing it at its source while
this does at first sound like it lines
up pretty well with the events of the
Battle 10,000 years ago as portrayed
here with those keywords automated and
force what if there's more to it than
that what if the ancient people of
Hyrule that according to this song
helped seal calamity Ganon at its source
keyword here being at its source by the
way which has been revealed to us to
most likely be ganondorf's body did so
in a different way now look again at the
glowing hand keeping ganondorf's body at
bay at this point the glowing blue-green
color should be all too familiar
especially when they teased the also
glowing blue-green luminous stones in
the very same trailer multiple times
what if the pose of the ancient hylians
are the souls of the dead that make
luminous stones glow like that but the
majority of them are right here
underground manifesting as this glowing
hand trying to keep calamity Ganon
sealed at its source how they're doing
this I'm not entirely sure but it may
have something to do with the strange
bracelets present all over the hand or
even the words spiralling out of it and
since there does seem to be an outward
spiral of the blue-green essence
seemingly dispersing away from the hand
what if we can find luminous stones
within the rocks of Hyrule because the
power of the pose is slowly being
dwindled away and dispersing into the
ground around it weakening as the
thousands of years have passed it's kind
of poetic that the spirit of Hyrule
itself has been keeping calamity Ganon
at bay all these years and perhaps
that's even why there wasn't a hero for
10,000 years
it all comes
back to the pose of Hyrule and that is
my theory on the pose and the hand and
the luminous rocks and the dead
champions man I was kind of all over the
place in this one wasn't I well I was
pretty speculative towards the end there
what do you think is the strange
luminous stone appearance in the trailer
deliberate is the glowing hand somehow
the amalgamation of the pose of Hyrule
or something way different let me know
in a comment below
hey you you there yeah I'm talking to
you thank you so much for watching and
as always huge thanks goes out to my
fantastic supporters of which I have a
new member say hello to the Zelda
connection who recently joined the ranks
of my elite supporters right here on
YouTube which by the way if you watching
are interested in getting your name up
here at the end of each video and some
fantastic perks you can do so without
even leaving youtube by clicking the
join button below this video or by
following the links in the description
also down there and also also down there
are links to my pages on the various
social media websites I am on so come on
over and say hi on my Twitter before I
wrap this up I wanted to show off some
awesome fan art that I received recently
check out these really neat pieces from
Rini and Mac mycelium in my discord
server I mean how could I not show these
off right there are so cool anyway this
is masking 10 event it's signing out I
hope you all have a great rest of your
day
[Music]